VO: Sickle-cell disease is one of the most prevalent
genetic conditions worldwide.
AMBROISE WONKAM: Every single year we have at least 300,000 newborns born withsickle-cell disease.
VO: The condition can cause sudden pain, as well as long-term joint and
organ damage, frequent infections, and anemia.
JIMI OLAGHERE: You can tell a sickle-cell patient by just shaking
their pocket, and if you hear pills dangling in
there you know this guy has chronic, chronic pain.
VO: Treatments are limited and the only curative solution, a
stem cell transplant, is not availableto everyone with sickle cell.
But new treatments are being trialled that could offer hope of a life
without symptoms to people with the condition,
and they work through gene editing.
HAYDAR FRANGOUL: If we canimprove the lives of patients with sickle-cell disease we are not only keeping them away fromthe hospital
we are actually allowing them to go to school, to go to work, to be with their
families.
I would not be heartbroken to see my floor have not a single patient with sickle-celldisease having any complications related to it.
JIMI: You have to try and lead a normal life as much
as possible but then you have this chip on your
shoulder that’s sickle cell that literally affects
every single decision you make, every single
thing, like when you wake up, how you wake up,
what you eat for breakfast, if you can go to work,
if you could take care of your kid.
VO: Over 6million people are living with sickle-cell disease worldwide,
three-quarters of them in sub-Saharan
Africa.
AMBROISE: Every single year we have at least 300,000
newborns born with sickle-cell disease and
80 percent of these children are born in Africa.
VO: Around five percent of the world's population
carries trait genes for haemoglobin disorders,
but that figure rises as high
as 25 percent in some regions.
Two parents carrying sickle-cell trait have a one
in four chance of having a child with sickle-celldisease.
JIMI: I was first diagnosed with sickle cell
at birth. I was fortunate enough to have parents
to bring me to the United States to do the
amniocentesis test, of course they both knew
they had the sickle-cell trait, both my parents
are Nigerian, uh living in Nigeria at the time.
Growing up, it was tough. Um I actually even,
I don't remember my first crisis but I have
a reminder. I have this little deformed, uh, finger
that doesn't grow as quick or didn't grow with the
rest of my fingers that was actually my first
crisis that it was so bad that it caused tissue
damage and that's why that finger didn't grow like
the rest of them.
VO: Pain is the most common symptom of sickle-cell disease.
As sickle cells travelthrough small blood vessels they can get stuck and clog blood flow causing what are known as paincrises.
JIMI: It was almost a revolving door every week,
in and out of the hospital, just trying to keep myhead above water.
AMBROISE: For the past 111 years where we know sickle-cell disease exists, we unfortunately have onlyfour medications that have been approved by the
FDA and hydroxyurea is the only one that is widely
available, but unfortunately not always accessible
in patients in Africa for example. So most of the
case patient will be treated symptomatically for
pain, will be treated symptomatically for anemia.
will be treated symptomatically for recurring
infection without a definitive treatment.
JIMI: I'vetried the lot.
I did hydroxyurea, at one point I did um, frequent blood transfusions
as well - thathelped for a while
then I did hydration therapy where it wasn't blood transfusions because they
were worried my iron levels were getting too high
so you know what we're just gonna
flush you with liquids every Tuesday.
VO: Until recently the only curative treatment for
sickle-cell disease was a stem cell transplant,
but this comes with its own risks and requires
a bone marrow donor who is a close match tothe recipient.
But now new treatments are being
developed that could allow anyone with sickle-cell
disease to lead a symptom-free life.
HAYDAR: We arecurrently treating patients with sickle-cell disease and beta thalassemia using a innovativetherapy called CRISPR-Cas9 gene editing.
VO: CRISPR-Cas9 is an enzyme that can be targeted
to make specific cuts in a cell's DNA.
HAYDAR: And this gene editing is used to target a specific gene to
allow the stem cells in those patients to produce
high levels of fetal haemoglobin.
VO: Sickle cell
is caused by a genetic mutation.
AMBROISE: Sickle-cell disease is due to a single nucleotide change
that alter the structure of haemoglobin, and haemoglobin is the protein that madeof 70 percent of red blood cell.
VO: Normally haemoglobin floats freely within a healthy
red blood cell transporting oxygen around
the body. But in sickle-cell disease
the structure of haemoglobin is altered.
Now after releasing oxygen to cells, the mutated
haemoglobin locks together, causing the shape
of the red blood cell to change from a pliable
donut to a more rigid, stickier, sickle shape.
Researchers are beginning to trial using CRISPR
to directly edit the sickle cell mutation
but Haydar Frangoul’s group are trying something
different.
HAYDAR: Interestingly, throughout evolution, babies in utero make high amounts of fetalhaemoglobin. Fetal haemoglobin is very efficient
in transporting oxygen. When babies are born
they switch from making fetal haemoglobin
to making adult haemoglobin which is haemoglobin
A. Haemoglobin A in the situation of sickle cell
patients has a mutation in it. In utero babies
do not experience any sickle cell crisis or
complications related to their disease and
what we know is we know that this BC11A
gene is what is making that switch, think about it
as a switch.
VO: BCL11A tells your stem cells to stop producing fetal haemoglobin.
By targeting it withCRISPR this treatment
switches fetal haemoglobin production back on.
HAYDAR: We know for a fact thatpatients with sickle-cell disease for example who have persistent high fetal haemoglobin
andthere are populations specifically in western Africa and in Saudi Arabia that persistto have high levels of fetal haemoglobin,
and those patients do not experience significant
complications related to their sickle-cell disease
and some of them are completely asymptomatic.
So what we are trying to do is we are trying to
make the cells make high number of fetal
haemoglobin and that fetal haemoglobin
can stabilize the red blood cell and prevent it
from sickling.
VO: And this trial is already showing exciting results for people like Jimi.
He had hisstem cells harvested, gene edited with CRISPR, and re-implanted back into his body where theystarted producing fetal haemoglobin.
JIMI: The outcome of this new treatment for me has been a miracle.
It was about a week maybe a week and change, I,
I could feel it, instantly, I could feel thelack of pain,
I felt, woah okay there's no pain, and usually because I'm attached to the
bed this throughout this whole period,
usually once a day I'll buzz my nurse
to help me out with pain medication and she'll
bring something and I didn't need that anymore,
all of a sudden I didn't need pain medication I,
I wanted to get up. Um, one of the weirdest things,
my eyes, usually because of sickle cell you
break down a lot of red blood cells and then it
shows in your eyes with the bilirubin and your
eyes become yellow. My eyes became white. Just
like pure white, which was of course I love that,
I've always wanted white eyes but it was just
a shock to me, I couldn't believe it, I had to
keep on like "is this... is this me?"
HAYDAR: The sevenpatients that received this treatment
all have benefited from it and have not experienced
any sickle-cell related complications after the treatment.
VO: This treatment can't repair damagethat sickle-cell disease has already caused, but it could prevent new problems from evenarising.
Unfortunately it's very expensive.
Transporting an individualized therapy like this
from a trial setting to where it is needed most
around the world will be an enormous challenge.
HAYDAR: My hope is if we show that this treatment works, and the preliminary data is very exciting,
thatI'm hoping that this therapy over time will be able to scaled up to treat patients all over theworld, as a scientist working with this therapy
this is my goal, is to help every patient
affected with sickle-cell disease in the future.
VO: Ambroise Wonkam is optimistic that this technology
could be used across the globe but he also knows
there is more to be done with the treatments we
already have.
AMBROISE: We know things that works for now for sickle-cell disease is newborn screening andthat newborn screening needs to be accompanied by
comprehensive care embedded in specialized
center for sickle-cell disease. We know
those simple public health intervention works and
those are the first thing to do, but it doesn't
mean that we should not add a curative alternative
for sickle-cell disease. So the future of gene
editing I do think have a place in low resources
setting, specifically if we find a way to make them
technologically accessible, cheaper, and safer.
JIMI: I love this poem by Walt Whitman, Pioneers! O Pioneers!
Uh, that's one of my favorite poems ever,
and I just feel like a pioneer. I don't mind being the guinea pig - in fact I relish this role, soi'm happy that i got this opportunity.
My thing is i just want to make sure that everyone gets this
opportunity as well, that's my biggest thing is
this is should be released as soon as possible and
it should be affordable and it should be global.